[Music]
and don't save me news Oh submitted by
big papa pepper jalapeno man was
forceful forcefully rescued after
spending three years on top of a coconut
tree oh you don't want to come down I
don't buy this you didn't what was he
like from from like war he liked sweater
what that straight-up sounds like an old
racist joke that has to be the beginning
of a racist joke a Filipino man climbs
up a coconut tree for three years yeah
from like back you know did it it has to
be there has to be some kind of he's
like like a tree house I'm assuming
right you can't just live like this so
he's just [ __ ] and peeing down the
tree yeah what are those things a little
what are those animals that don't like
sloths long they do they just [ __ ] right
off the tree no they don't actually they
actually take 30 minutes to slow [ __ ]
to go down the tree and then they [ __ ]
and they bury it so uh are you making
this 100 other predators don't attack
them in a check another 45 minutes to
get up the [ __ ] tree but they're
gonna attack them on the 45 minute wait
that's what I then do that's what they
do what up hit when they just like [ __ ]
themselves or peeing their pants on the
way down ha yeah how does the sloth
survive like we're talking about sloth I
hope so no tell me you know how they
move slow right there's a bridge yeah
and they're so stupid like the hold onto
this these by the way how was it a zoo
and I wanted my flock do you want to
feed a sloth I go sure this is how lazy
these [ __ ] are right I'm gonna give
you an example he gave me this giant
stick with a carrot or whatever and I
put it right up to the [ __ ] it was
feeding time and I put it right in his
claw right here yeah
they don't care I don't know why they're
alive they're cute like who'd why
wouldn't people just eat all sloths like
all the animals in the kingdom they made
it
probably tastes like [ __ ] yeah there's
probably something I'm saying yeah eat
my lazy ass like a live eats like or
some kind of creature
eases they get made fun of because it's
just such easy meal kibble you ate a
sloth you [ __ ] lazy [ __ ] that makes
sense that makes sense this man here is
not as lucky boy ah 47 years old his
name is Gilbert d'hubert why why does
that tiger behind yeah yeah I said
Gilbert three years ago he said that he
was hit on the head with a gun by
someone and just randomly just randomly
there's a coconut it was his mother who
good morning you got so scared and like
terrified for his life and he thought
that someone was gonna come and kill him
so immediately he what climbed up the
coconut tree that's outside is its home
where he lives with his mom and his two
daughters phone he could have called
9-1-1 but he leaves his kids and his mom
alone
and he [ __ ] i tell and he climbs up
the tree get this bucket how what do you
say about that he's a piece of [ __ ]
coward well no he got hit with a gun
right in his head so he probably went
coconuts okay you know who's crazy
something happened you wouldn't live up
in the coconut world if you weren't oh
yeah he climbed up six is 360 feet up 60
feet yes drawback in 2014 is when he did
hug dude how'd he stay up there and
sleep without falling oh I don't know
what that but I know he survived because
his mom would send him food water
cigarette yeah can you give me a back
out of my bro lights puff it up what
about his two daughters exactly the
Linda
is it is it work
is it like the kids mom or his mom his
own mother mother they she died during
childbirth of this all that's so then um
the his Gilbert's mom has been taking
care of the girls and now she was saying
like you know I'm getting too old like I
can't take your kids to school you need
to come down so for all these years
they've been trying to get him to come
down talking also yelling at each other
- yeah I'm still scared
yeah then has he made any attempts to
like come down like kind of like you
know when people are coming out of the
darks just to like check their you like
coming down it goes bad right yeah it
does he's obviously sick right yeah so
then um so the family they had been they
had been trying to get authorities to
help them get him down
yeah just shoot him down okay cut the
tree or cat [ __ ] put it on fire just
shake the [ __ ] out of that tree you know
yeah so then no one would do anything
cuz they're like well it's his choice he
wants to be up there oh well we're not
gonna do anything about it so then
finally recently there was a post that
went viral
like someone wrote about him yes post
went viral and then that's when
authorities were like okay I guess we'll
help the family so then they spent four
hours cutting the tree down in like
slowly dropping the tree to the ground
so he would be safe while he's still
stuck on it yeah well how are they gonna
prevent him climbing him in the truth
yeah well they really gonna go get like
psychiatric evaluation so there is
something mentally wrong with them
because of the gun here yeah they said
that he had signs of psychosis well he
was up in a tree so I'm not sure if
that's from the gun hit I mean it could
have been the fact that he survived
three years of typhoon in the
Philippines in a [ __ ] tree yeah
that's the thing too because they're
like all these years like it didn't
matter what about the weather
[Laughter]
he also had a purse this is up there in
a bolo like a machete machete so they've
never seen it because of that Boulder
like he had cuz apparently had a huge
bolo that he saw his bolos here job that
like they were really trying to be
careful of bringing the tree down oh
yeah yeah but he cut his hair with the
scissors right yeah he do cut his own
hair with this is he did whoa there's a
picture of this guy you know what you
say that super cut because he keeps
hiding his fate he's still like he's
grabbing leaves and he's convinced
that's almost trying to kill oh yeah
he's touched in the head there yeah you
let me show you got the clip Oh when
they brought the tree down the elements
didn't kill ya so here's a clip of when
they were bringing the tree down team
bar Juicery they were calling him
colloid
because it was a fake name that they
gave him she was too scared of you oh my
god that's so high palm tree not doing
this the right way that does not even
sound like a language said don't judge
[ __ ] Athena's not
does not look like they're handling it
very gently where is how did how did
they get the food up there like did they
have like a rope rope the mom would pick
it up burn yeah with the Rope enabler
well she wanted her son to be a lie like
she was trying to help him first we just
leave you to die three years why did
this happen two years and 11 months ago
the rescue yeah because no one wanted to
help after a month in a coconut tree
let's do something yeah and you know
what else is creepy when he came down
they discovered that his body was so
deformed from spending so many you like
this [ __ ] up of course I bet you he's
got crazy grip strength though oh yeah I
wanna I would have loved to see him
climb that tree to begin with yeah hi
how do you do that you know when you say
sixty feet I didn't think it was that
tall though 60 feet is pretty high
that's pretty much six stories I thought
he just got lazy like once he got up
there he was like you know this is kind
of nice no work just hang out here all
day yeah cigarettes of food he does that
figure with daughters anymore that's
flame retardant after having a
psychiatrist look at him they said that
he exhibits symptoms of psychosis
including delusions and hallucinations
and obviously that the fear of someone
killing him it's like would give you
this psychiatrist for that
what the [ __ ] the night being put on
medication I want what he has without
the paranoia
by the way he had a healthy diet of
coconut water though I mean that's right
that's that's the best thing you could
have right in a great view of his town
yeah what do you want that he has
coconut fun his grip strength is really
strong because as it was shaking he's
still been to come down yeah well
actually what am I talking my type foods
he's a writer that's me yeah
well how do you sleep I know I don't
know how would you make that movie yeah
how could a tree not be the coconut man
yeah and it's just a guy in a tree the
whole moving you have to really make it
interesting with cool shots and why not
it sounds like a Sundance onesie
it's like cast away but like coconut man
yeah like his own decision to cook it
refuses to come down everyone's like
please come down you have kids here well
the villain is the village you know one
of the coconut it wouldn't be Wilson but
it did the anti Wilson Oh coconut that's
mean
well when the token already has two eyes
and a mouth yeah what was name be
instead of Wilson I don't Coco yeah Coco
yeah but it took 50 people to take them
down 50 I don't get it yeah
Cory's mentally ill yeah it's not just
human poop everywhere around that tree
oh yeah yeah it must smell so bad I have
a feeling his mom picked it up and human
poop smells bad yeah compared to every
other atom tofu dude yeah it just had is
so gross you know it's pretty amazing is
that a person with psychosis is still
addicted to cigarettes oh yeah you'd
think like he's scared for his life so
he's just like I'm just gonna be like
you know protect myself and I don't care
about anything I just need the most
basic nutrients but he's still like he's
getting my Marlboro Reds not my same
like that mom [ __ ] up cuz she just had
a cut off his like smoky zap like he
might have come down yeah well I have an
addiction in a blur yeah
[Music]